you have written books about history let  me ask you the president yesterday  broadly declared that he has the  absolute right to pardon himself he does  and then the Congress has the absolute  right to impeach him that's what would  happen if a president was dumb enough to  pardon themselves there would be such an  act this would be such an arrogant  statement of power that the house would  probably impeach him within a week and  the Senate would convicted but why do  you think he throws that out there he  says it on one hand Trump learned in New  York City media the churning works you  know you do something this morning and  by this afternoon you do something else  and by this evening to do something else  and everybody's busy Treach running  around chasing each other and he's done  it to his whole career since the 1980s